you vous dites que vous êtes ingérable
oui j'ai quand même pris quelques bonnes
résolutions pour 2006 j'espère on va
faire une interview bonnes résolutions
bongo alors les bonnes résolutions en
2006 est ce que vous allez arrêter de
fumer non est-ce que vous allez arrêter
là est ce que vous allez arrêter toute
drogue
est ce que vous allez faire un régime
non pas pour quoi faire est-ce que vous
avez bien sinon c'est vrai ce que vous
allez faire un septième enfant oui ah
oui
tu vas voir le prix cognac jane
carrey prend les contes de fées mal à
faire les sept nains
lio est ce que vous allez mettre un
petit peu d'argent de côté
pour l'enfant pour le septième au moins
j'ai tellement de dette j'ai plutôt les
rendre ses pattes noires de faire un
lieu dont
d'ailleurs excusé moi oui absolument je
signale que toutes les ventes de mon
disque dit au prince charmant sont
reversés à une fondation qui s'appelle
sauver les enfants de lio donc acheter
ce disque s'il vous plaît par milliers
parce que franchement ça va m'aider
énormément
si dragon de lancer une opération pièces
blanches se prépare parce que les pièces
jaunes vous les fils adam chirac ce qui
reste dans votre poste de monnaie vous
les filets lio est décédé gros 500 au
moins là on sait vraiment où ça va et
c'est assez pour nourrir les petits et
bien gérée j'aimerais bien tu sais mais
je sais
est ce que vous êtes tombée amoureuse
est ce que vous aller baiser comme une
folle
bassi veut bien est-ce que vous allez
reprendre le cinéma est ce que vous
allez faire des concerts ouais si vous
avez changé de coiffure non est ce que
vous avez mangé mais des perruques a
comme moi
peu de copies la sauce je vais pas
passer celles que j'ai
moi je passerai ligne n ya pas de
problème se pose est est-ce que vous
avez vous réconcilier avec quelqu'un je
meurs concilie avec tout le monde moi
moi j'ai pas de rancoeur je connais pas
ça est-ce que vous avez tiré un trait
sur certaines personnes
passent eux tirent un trait toute seule
elle même alors du coup j'ai plus
travaillé à faire oui est-ce que vous
avez corriger certains défauts
mais qu'est ce que j'ai comme défaut
terry aucun lieu au mas voilà quand je
n'ai rien à la solution comparable sur
qui on des philippines voilà est-ce que
vous allez faire la chirurgie esthétique
and vous avez pas besoin en même temps
je pourrai si elle a besoin comme tout
le monde mais non ça m'emmerde c'est
long c'est douloureux qu on a puis on
n'a pas de temps avant tout cas moi j'ai
pas le temps pour ça est ce que vous
avez couché les animateurs tv and on
annonce en date qu'est ce qu'il ya comme
boîte de cul dans le 17ème offert
formidable alors vous raconter une
anecdote 6 e de seconde
non parce que c'est quand même un des
trucs les plus humiliants qui me soit
arrivée de ma vie je tournais avec
gérard depardieu la fin de tenu de
soirée gérard était en gare sont en cuir
un petit peu hyper maquiller moi j'étais
en travelo mais comme c'était comme
c'était entre deux prises quand il y
avait du temps de réglage
j'avais pas ma perruque et j'avais des
moonboots sous ma jupe et gérard ivre
mort maudit rien je vais t'emmener dans
un an une boîte sympa l'avant là il ya
un truc très sympa où on a tourné avec
le maurice pialat là tu vas voir c'est
vachement bien l'endroit bien avec moi
sinon gérard il était déjà un petit peu
avancé je me suis dit on récupérera
jamais dit non non gérard on va pas
aller si tu vois c'est une boîte à
partouze que sympa toi non gérard j'ai
pas mes vieux norrois guérit pas et il
part tout seul et je me dis on va jamais
le retrouver donc je lui file le train
on arrive une rue tout à fait anonyme
une porte cochère d'immeubles très 17e
l'ats une porte avec une entrée
d'immeuble normale et une petite porte
dans le hall de l'immeuble en face de
l'ascension une petite porte avec un
judas donc tout ça sent très très bon
l'échangisme
gérard s'accroche viola jour tu
sonnes et à ce moment là un monsieur
descend de son appartement 17e pas du
tout et j'en ris tu nous vois tous les
deux mois en jupe cette petite thierry
mugler qui valait si bien avec les bons
outils et les fossiles maquillé comme
amérique sans perruque gérard en cuir et
nous regarder nous fait vous allez là
c'est coquin
je me suis dit il est parti je me
souviendrai composé de honte mais là
l'expression vous allez là c'est
qu'aucun dans le genre qui sont ensemble
ils vont s'envoyer en l'air lui en
travelo avec des moonboots c'est ça et
et l'humiliation la victoire
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in
a l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux